[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well
who do we have here grew up in haywood
whole street was my family
[Music]
neighbors helped each other out thought
nothing of it
i'm pleased to see you have not
forgotten dudes
[Music]
born here live here die here
childhood memories
get the [ __ ] out of vista it keeps
getting jumped you find some stronger
tubers
do you want to spend the rest of your
days blasting scabs
or become a legend overnight
we have a ride
[Music]
ready to get your cherry popped yeah
come on
[Applause]
my childhood let's see
racing my bobber for the first time
through the hills
oh and the first kiss in the middle of a
synth cornfield
we nomads choose who to make our family
a choice forges strong bonds and a
higher duty that stands solid as an old
oak
[Music]
my family's in pieces that's why i'm
headed for night city
makes you an outcast among outcasts
miss this you know camaraderie
i know i saw it in your heart the first
time you met
[Music]
know what i always liked about nomads
your taste no
hunger for freedom not easy to come by
in night city
corps got their grubby claws and
everything
[Music]
i have those reports you asked for they
were supposed to be ready yesterday
the world's going to tear us apart when
the word gets around
the world's never going to find out
if i go down you're going down with me
no i'm not [ __ ] joking this isn't
a request v but no way you're [ __ ]
right
you're the one who fixes other people's
[ __ ] if you work in our soccer counter
intel
you're always [ __ ]
today they got you to zero somebody
tomorrow look at somebody else to zero
you
what's the rules jack want to be top
gotta have some skin in the game yeah
but you're not on top it's a boro
and here the pendejo keeps work for
yourself
live for yourself that's the only way
you